신경망은 강력한 머신러닝 알고리즘의 한 종류야
그리고 다양한 종류가 있어
입문 영상에서 신경망에 대해 제대로
다루기는 어렵지
이 영상에서는 신경망의 핵심 구성 요소 몇 가지만
그리고 전체적인 작업 흐름만 살펴볼게
그래야 양자 컴퓨팅이 어떻게 기여할 수 있는지 이해할 수 있으니까
신경망은 뉴런들이 연결된 그래프야
뉴런은 기본적으로 그냥 숫자를 담는 것이고
그 숫자를 흔히 활성화 값이라고 불러, 뉴런이
얼마나 켜져 있는지 꺼져 있는지를 나타내지
뉴런들은 레이어로 정렬되어 있어
첫 번째 레이어가 입력 레이어고
마지막은 출력 레이어야
그 사이에는 처리에 사용되는 레이어가 있는데
히든 레이어라고 불러, 입력 레이어의
활성화 값은 분석할 데이터에서 직접 불러와
예를 들어 이미지의 픽셀 음영 같은 것들이지
다음 히든 레이어의 활성화 값은
입력 레이어의 뉴런들에 의해 결정되고
모든 뉴런을 연결하는 선으로 표현되는 가중치에 의해서도 결정돼
입력 레이어의 모든 뉴런들을
다음 레이어의 뉴런들과 연결하는 거지, 즉 히든 레이어의
뉴런 활성화 값은
모든 입력 활성화 값의
가중합으로 구해, 또
편향도 적용할 수 있어, 일종의 이동값인데
히든 레이어의 뉴런을 활성화하고 싶을 때
가중합이 양수일 때만이 아니라
큰 임계값을 초과할 때만 활성화되도록 할 수 있어
그런 다음 복잡한 함수를 적용해서 활성화 값을 구하는데
0과 1 사이의 값으로, 쌍곡 탄젠트 같은 거야
아니면 때로는
정류 선형 유닛을 쓰기도 해, 지금 당장
이런 것들에 대해 너무 걱정하지 않아도 돼
여기서 이 함수들에 대해 중요하게 알아야 할 건
비선형이라는 점이야
그래서 네트워크 전체가 선형과
비선형 요소를 모두 포함하게 되는 거지
이번에는 같은 활성화 값의 가중합을
첫 번째 히든 레이어의
활성화 값과 새 가중치로 시작해서
다음 히든 레이어까지 확장해
이게 출력인 마지막 레이어까지 계속되는 거야
출력 레이어에는 각 카테고리에 해당하는
뉴런들이 있고, 활성화 값이 알려주는 건
네트워크가 그 분류를 얼마나 확신하는지야
예를 들어 이미지 분석의 출력 카테고리가
개, 고양이, 햄스터 이런 식이라면
개 뉴런의 활성화 값이 0.95라면
그 이미지가 개일 가능성이 높다는 걸 나타내는 거야
신경망을 처음 시작할 때는 무작위 가중치로 시작할 수도 있고
무작위 가중치와
편향으로, 또는 알려진 합리적인 초기 구성으로 시작하기도 해
하지만 그다음 핵심은
신경망이 얼마나 잘 분류하는지 확인하고
개선하는 거야, 비용 함수를 사용해서
신경망이 얼마나 벗어나는지 나타내
정확한 분류에서, 이건 이미지의 실제 값과
예를 들어 개 뉴런의 값이 1이고
다른 모든 출력 뉴런은 0인 경우와
예측값의 차이를 구하는 거야
그리고 예측값과 비교하는 거지
모든 카테고리를 합산하는데
올바른 카테고리가 가장 많이 활성화됐는지뿐만 아니라
잘못된 활성화 값이
줄어드는지도 추적할 수 있어
훈련 데이터 전체의 모든 예시를 합산해서
비용을 구하고 그다음
각 레이어의 가중치 같은 파라미터를
모든 뉴런 사이와 모든 편향값을 조정해
고전적인 최적화 루틴을 사용해서
비용 함수의 지역 최솟값을 찾는 거야
이 복잡성을 줄이기 위한 조치를 취하지 않으면
얼마나 어마어마한
파라미터 공간을 만들어 놓은 건지 상상이 갈 거야
천 개의 픽셀로 이미지를 분석하도록 설계된 신경망을
생각해봐, 이 신경망은 천 개의 입력 뉴런과
단 하나의 히든 레이어
그리고 고양이 또는 개 같은 이진 출력을 가질 수 있어
이게 가장 단순한 경우인데
그래도 천 곱하기 천, 즉
백만 개의 가중치가 입력과 히든 레이어 사이에 있어
그리고 히든 레이어와
출력 레이어 사이에 또 2000개가 있지
거기에 천 개 정도의
편향도 있을 수 있어, 이 간단한 신경망만 해도
백만 개가 훨씬 넘는 파라미터에 해당하는 거야, 물론 공평하게 말하면
현대 알고리즘들은 보통 간소화를 하기도 하고
고전 신경망에서는
이 최소화를 가능하게 만들고
효율적으로 만드는 데 전념하는 분야들도 있어
하지만 이게 매우
고차원적인 문제라는 사실은 변하지 않아
그리고 신경망을 훈련시키는 건
시간이 굉장히 많이 걸릴 수 있어
비용도 많이 들고, 양자 신경망 또는 QNN은
먼저 입력 데이터를 불러오고
그다음 quantum circuits을 적용해서
레이어 사이의 가중치에 해당하는
마지막으로 측정 레이어를 적용해
여기서 몇 가지 핵심 사항이 있는데, 데이터
불러오기와 가중치는 선형 연산이야
하지만 측정은 비선형이야
그래서 고전 신경망처럼 선형과
비선형 요소가 모두 있는 거야
또한 가중치 circuits은
여전히 변분 파라미터를 가지고 있어
그래서 고전적인 최소화 과정이 여전히 필요해
물론 이건 양자 신경망의 표면만 살짝
긁은 거지만, 양자 신경망의 응용 분야에 대해
계속 배워나가길 바라
그리고 다른 양자 머신러닝 응용 분야도
IBM Quantum과 함께